costco founder
once told the company current ceo if you
raise the price of effing hot dog i will
kill you costco has charged a buck 50
for its hot dog and soda combo since
1985 and a quote from costco founder
jim chenegal explains why that is
jealous took over as ceo when chenego
retired in 2012 and the hot dogs
populatory has only grown in 2019 costco
sold 151 million hot dogs
combos for a total of 226 million
dollars so what are your thoughts about
this guy saying i'll kill you if you
sell the hot dogs
here's my first thought he's probably
the only executive that was in a in a
corporate setting like that where he has
to
had to ask himself is this worth dying
over i don't think so
right um raising the price you know i
guess it's iconic since 1985 they
haven't raised the price but i don't
blame the current ceo
one bit for wanting to a who's gonna
notice a nickel difference right
you might get upset the first time but
you're still gonna pay it when you think
of the volume of costco that's huge
bucks
plus look around mlb all right they
charge
five bucks at major league baseball
games five dollars
average for a hot dog and they're not
that good except for the dollars your
dogs are more than that no they've got
an average
yeah they are eight or nine bucks um so
you got the deal you got the half off
deal let me go i'm gonna roll with you
when i go to a game from now on so they
in mlb parks in 2019 100 million hot
dogs
or 100 million in revenue over 20
million hot dogs so there's a lot of
money in hot dogs
by the way here's a trivia question how
many hot dogs sold at major league
ballparks in 2020
okay can i can i guess how many hot dogs
sold at major league ballparks in 2020
why are you saying zero kai said zero
he's right they don't allow fans in the
stands this year pandemic
the pandemic dog all right i was about
to do math in my mind
anyway i was the quick one where'd you
go with that where were you going i was
gonna do math 162 games
times 30 something teams times you know
i was going to do the whole show
he was going to einstein it up at zero
actually let's just do it for the
for the hell of it so if you got 162
games actually let's see how many this
is
times 30 times uh how many thousand fans
fifty thousand on average is that a
fair number that's way way too very high
i'd say twenty
twenty two twenty five thousand well if
you're talking uh miami marlins games
maybe
twenty five thousand how many people buy
hot dogs a hundred percent of people buy
hot dogs definitely not
i i would say uh 20 so it's only 121
million yeah if everybody buy one hot
dog
it's 121 million it's not that many hot
dogs yeah it's very disappointing
we should buy more hot dogs right but
here's by the way this episode is
sponsored by oscar meyer weiner get you
uh uh uh oscar wiener and playboy
magazine
we got hot dogs and playboy combo watch
this year but watch us here
should the former founder have the right
to tell the existing ceo
if you raise the prices on the hot dog
i'm going to kill you
i don't think murder over hot dogs
should ever be the answer let's bring
this country together i mean
does he have any ownership stake right i
mean we talked about this briefly
you as a ceo you sell your company right
yes you know
uh you sell costco okay you you you
loved your hot dogs you were selling
them for a nickel a piece whatever it
was
as a ceo who sold his company what say
do you have in the in the hot dog
dilemma well the tricky part about this
is costco's
founder once once
told the company's current ceo what is
once
is it when he first became a ceo in 2012
and he was still the executive
chairman of the board i don't know what
once means but let's let's unpack that
if it's he's the executive chairman of
the board
while he hires the ceo fine i get that
but if he
retired as the uh board in january 2018
and you sell your shares and you no
longer have no stake in the company
listen if the guy wants to raise a price
he can raise a price this speaks volumes
of what the current ceo thinks of the
old ceo right how many products are
first how many skus are there in a
costco
20 000. yeah they let that guy have say
over
one thing you can have the hot dog in
the food court that's what they told him
they're gonna let him go
a buck fifty forever by the way do they
taste good i've never had a costco hot
dog i've never had one
i've never had it either are they worth
more would you taste like hot dogs
i have no idea here's what i'm like
imagining right
i line up a conference call we gotta
have a talk we gotta have a list of
issues we're gonna be discussing today
we gotta have a board of directors seat
we're gonna have a
conference call let's get everybody up
we're on here we on the call if you
raise the goddamn price of that hot dog
buddy i'm gonna find you
i'm gonna kill you i'm gonna hunt you
down i'm gonna murder you that's it
that's the end of the call like
i would love that that was the only
purpose if that if they're expecting the
hot duck to be a buck 50 50 years from
now you've lost your mind
i mean it's just you've lost your mind
purely inflation wise if everybody on
average gets a three percent raise the
average hot dog should get a three
percent raise in price right however
however i will tell you this that's
their best employee if the
hot dog is the linchpin that brings
people in you got to keep it at that
price
if because but i've never known costco
as a hot dog place
i've just known pizza and coke i never
thought about the hot dogs
can't you see the movie ten years from
now costco
the hot dog starring liam neeson take
him
if you do not raise the cost of the hot
dog i will let you go
we will be fine but if you do i will
hunt you down
i will find you and i will kill you
and i will kill you costco hot dog is
the best
you